vor zwei jahren hat chelsea bei uns ein
praktikum gemacht und jetzt ist sie
zurück
willkommen galt sie dann wie geht's dir
sehr gut ich bin sehr froh zurück in
berlin zu sein
es ist doch schön wie immer zufällig ist
es so schön wie du gegangen ist ist es
jetzt wieder
und was ist deine frage heute ja heute
ein thema ist
und was war dein schlechteste steht das
will ich auch unbedingt wissen kennt sie
hier ist ein mikrofon danke los geht's
[Musik]
was ist schon mal auf ein schlechtes
date kannst du mir davon erzählt er
ja auf jeden fall ich glaube ich bin
auch nicht der einzige
das war ein sehr kurzes sieht auch weil
wir auch gerade gemerkt haben dass wir
gar nicht zueinander passen
und was hat dir dann gemacht wir haben
uns im restaurant verabredet
es war auch merkwürdig weil wir
teilweise nicht mehr wussten worüber man
reden sollte und deswegen also es war
wirklich eine eine unangenehme stille
teilweise da
und danach haben wir glaube ich nur
hände geschüttelt wenn ich mich richtig
uns das war es dann auch
mein bruder hat ein schlechtes data hat
sie am ende ihre freundin mitgebracht
die dann zu ihr meinte er solle sich
verpissen das hat er vorgestern erzählt
das war ein schlechtes bild
das ist das was mir zu viele schlechte
dazu kannst du mir davon
typisch sicherer geschichte erzählen
horrorgeschichte in brüssel ihr date
kinder nummer eins und es geht an zahlen
und dann hat er gesagt ja ich verdienen
ja dreieinhalbtausend im monat
deswegen zahle ich das und dann habe ich
gesagt ja ich verdient 4000 im monat was
machen wir jetzt
das war das erste das war dann er
kurzzeitig mal sagen genau und warum mal
schlecht weil wir uns von anfang an in
die nicht wirklich verstanden habe und
was hast du dann gemacht
dann habe ich passiv wäre weil ich finde
wenn man sich schon trifft dann ist es
außerdem wichtig dass man sich zeit
nimmt ich habe mir schon die zeit
genommen und dann habe ich gesagt okay
let's go oder anderes und der war
richtig
und das habe ich gemerkt und dann habe
ich ihm allem eine sex geschichten
erzählt und wir haben uns auch nie
wieder gesehen
ich kam viel zu spät welchen des
wahlstation ausgestiegen bin was schon
sehr schlecht waren zwar berlin wind
also ziemlich kalt dann nach einer
halben stunde haben wir uns dann
getroffen und sie war natürlich ziemlich
angepisst das verständlich war
aber ja so hat so wirklich so die
gemeinsamkeiten daten was sehen wir
insgesamt hätten machen können oder wie
könnte vielleicht ein schlecht
schiefgehen gehen ja vielleicht wenn man
einfach die person anders erwartet als
sie dann letztendlich ist ja und wenn
man mit einem anderen meint setting an
die ganze sache rangeht
und ja also ist es was das leben ja das
keine schlechte jetzt geben wenn man
nichts mehr zu erzählen hat weil man
sich gegenseitig nicht gefällt aber am
schlimmsten ist wenn einer dem anderen
schon gefällt und der andere will weg
dass der andere schlecht riecht oder so
man ist eigentlich aus wie würdest du
einen schlechten vorstellen dass man so
ganz andere erwartungen hat was man sich
zum beispiel ganze hoffnung macht und
die andere person aber ganz andere
hoffnung an dass zeit hat und es dann
nicht klappt keine andere sexy sadie
sein die an die fusion ehrlich sagen das
lässt das
das wäre ja vermehrt zum beispiel ich
würde es hassen wenn der andere nur auf
ein handy selbst bestimmt total es gibt
es ein logo handy am besten zu in der
tasche lassen er ich glaube an das hast
du das schlimmste ist was passieren
könnte ist dass die stimmung hat so gar
nicht funktioniert dass man sich
vielleicht vorher gar nicht kannte und
dann miteinander versucht ins gespräch
zu kommen
aber sie überhaupt kein kein einziges
thema hat über das man reden kann
deswegen habe ich so mein albtraum kann
dann so peinliche stille die ganze zeit
und dann was macht man dann wenn das
passiert einfach gehen
schau mal wir gehen einfach durch die
straße und die ich sehen gerade jetzt
ein werbung für bomben
das ist auch ähnlich zu tindall aber wo
die mädchen immer des ersten text
schreiben muss also es ist sehr populär
und wir sehen gerade im ruhrtal an
werbung für das netzwerk auf dem
internet
[Musik]
kann so kannst du mir mal erzählen wie
das schlechteste gang ist ja aber
wahrscheinlich in meiner jugend gab es
so katastrophale dates wenn zum beispiel
mit neuen mädchen ins kino gegangen und
dann habe ich versucht mein meine scheu
zu überwinden und habe einfach quasi auf
kommando mich gezwungen sich zu küssen
und wir sind aber sehr stark mit den
zähnen aufeinander geraten und das war
völlig schlecht her denken sie dass es
gibt gerade jetzt eine veränderung ist
es die kultur sich verändert hat um sich
zu verabreden weil sie um einen rang
die wut zu haben na ja meine beziehung
zu haben mit dem man ja sicher heute
geht das über internet ganz einfach aber
das ist nicht meine welt
jawohl und sie denken es war bestimmt
vorher anders kennen da sauber bis
besser war weiß ich nicht
auf jeden fall ich glaube es ist so
geworden man schlägt einfach eine neue
seite auf wenn man sich nicht mehr
meldet eine freundin hatte gerade drei
dates mit dem gleichen mann und er hat
das auch immer angeleiert
und jetzt nach dem dritten welt hat er
sie gekostet
also meldet sich nicht mehr aber die
nummer geht noch und das finde ich
einfach es ist so beliebig geworden
die verbindlichkeit ist ein bisschen weg
und man weiß einfach es gibt was neues
in der nächsten ecke und das finde ich
schade weil der respekt vor dem menschen
glaube ich ein bisschen flirten geht
dadurch dass man online in so einer welt
ist einfach das finde ich es gab zeiten
da gab es auch noch nicht für studenten
noch nicht unbedingt ein telefon dann
das in der zeit habe ich studiert dann
gingen wir einfach dahin wo wir die
anderen treffen wollten
in echt und jetzt läuft ja alles nur
noch über diese fotos aber keine ahnung
es ist ein falsches thema für mich ich
bin dafür zu alt und merkst du eben ein
unterschied wie das töten dating kultur
ist wie vielleicht vorher wie unsere
großeltern sich kennen gelernt haben
oder er das definitiv ein mega
unterschied ich glaube durch die apps da
hat man halt einfach mehr auswahl und
ich glaube man konzentriert sich nicht
so gut auf eine person sondern man sagt
sich mit am nächsten tag nächste version
also ich glaube das ist schon ziemlich
schade er ich kann mir vorstellen dass
leichter wird eben über die medien und
kinder et cetera und dass man früher war
es wahrscheinlich viel schwieriger erst
mal ein date zu haben
wie haben sie den partner kennengelernt
tatsächlich ist das langjährige
freundschaft schon gewesen also aus
kinderzeit
meine eltern haben sich im club
kennengelernt das erste mal
meine mutter ist dann für sieben monate
als au pair nach england gegangen
und mein vater konnte kein englisch die
haben sich neun monate briefe
geschrieben und dann hat er sie
überrascht und es mit dem auto nach
england hochgefahren um sie abzuholen
und das ist sozusagen der grund warum es
nicht gibt weil das man das war der
beginn dass sie zusammen waren dann
kälte besitze frieden mit den antworten
ja es gab sehr interessanten aber noch
keinen echten horror geschichte von
einen ganz schlechten tag hast du
vielleicht eine für uns hast du ein hort
erlebt nein eigentlich nicht
vielleicht einmal von deinen freunden
hast du eine witzige geschichte ja ja
nein weil weise ich glaube meine
generation macht es in denen nicht so
viel ist es einfach nur gesund hin oder
her genau die magen des begriff nicht in
denen nein das geht nicht und trifft
sich für ein raum wo unten ein
aber es ist zu formal oder sie haben
angst ist zu fragen oder ja wenn er
schon und dann das ist etwas anders
was ist anders na ja es gibt etwas
ruckelig vielleicht kinder ist nur ein
körperlich aber um eine echte personen
mit echten interessen kennen zu lernen
guckt man netflix
naja dann gut dann so viele hätten wir
geklärt wie das die jugend in
kalifornien heutzutage macht wie man
sich dort kennenlernen danke dass du
dabei warst viel spaß gemacht jetzt
wollen wir uns auf eure geschichten was
waren die schlechtesten dates die er je
hatte
schreibt uns unbedingt einen kommentar
wir freuen uns darauf und lernt weiter
deutsch zum beispiel mit unseren
interaktiven übungen die ihr auch zu
diesem video bekommt wenn ihr ein
mitglied seit und ein mitglied werdet
ihr bei patchen
das geht hier und wir sehen uns nächste
woche wieder
wir sehen
ist
[Musik]